[Música]
quando comecei a pesquisar um pouco
sobre os últimos relatórios sobre o
futuro do trabalho encontra informações
como essa
os dez empregos mais procurados
atualmente não existiam há dez anos
atrás 65% das crianças que estão na
escola hoje vão trabalhar em um emprego
que ainda não foi inventado 50 por cento
da força de trabalho humana vai perder o
seu trabalho para robôs e software nos
próximos 20 anos
que merda
aí eu fiquei pensando gente como é que
esses caras fazem esses levantamentos
todos eles se encontram num quarto
como é que eles escrevem essas coisas e
deixam a gente completamente alterado e
aí eu conseguir ir em uma reunião de
cientistas que planejam o futuro do
trabalho e eu trouxe uma foto pra vocês
é mais ou menos assim a gente faz um
pouco de tudo e como é que pode passar
uma mensagem bem marcante de bastante
terror e ver quem consegue assustar um
pouco mais as pessoas com relação ao
futuro do trabalho mas muito bem
eu não tenho medo do trabalho eu amo
trabalho eu acho que o trabalho da forma
que a gente tem de colocar a nossa
intenção no mundo a nossa
individualidade mas de fato o trabalho
está mudando e principalmente o trabalho
que a gente conhece como emprego e
quando ouve essas pesquisas felipão tem
dois problemas aqui na primeira conhecer
como é que a reunião descobrir o segundo
era tá tudo errado porque realmente acho
que algum roubou um software vai roubar
o meu trabalho e aí eu descobri que um
site que você pode pesquisar olha lá
will robinson eike workshop e você vai
lá e digitar o seu trabalho
eu sou formado em contabilidade digitei
meu trabalho à causa anti e vai vir o
percentual de probabilidade de um robô
tomar o seu posto de trabalho 94% e
ainda vem com essa frase bem
reconfortante e onde quem inglês é a
tradução do teu ruim pato
aí falei não mas eu sou formado em
contabilidade eu entendi muito cedo o
que eu posso fazer o que eu quiser no
mundo do trabalho e eu fui me tornando
um franquista e pegando um monte de
novos conhecimentos para conseguir
contribuir tem outra coisa que eu sei
fazer o trabalho com o desenvolvimento
humano de pessoas então vou procurar
treinamento e desenvolvimento de pessoas
coloquei no software fiquei mais
tranquilo porque veio 1.4 por cento de
chance de um robô tomar
estamos garantidos mas obviamente as
respostas não estão nesse site
é a forma de trabalho que a gente
conhece hoje pelo emprego realmente ela
vai mudar por favor não aceita não
acessem o site
mesmo que ele fala que é 1.4 está
mentindo é 100%
os robôs e softwares vão roubar o que a
gente conhece como emprego mas eles não
vão roubar o nosso trabalho ea nossa
capacidade produtiva
a maioria das pesquisas foca no que as
pessoas vão fazer no futuro do trabalho
quais são os postos de trabalho onde vai
abrir mais vagas qual é o tipo de
conhecimento
eu como pesquisador do mundo do trabalho
do relacionamento das pessoas com as
organizações têm muito mais interesse em
como a gente vai trabalhar no futuro e
ainda mais profundamente eu quero saber
porque é que a gente vai trabalhar no
futuro
até hoje o modelo principal de
relacionamento com o trabalho foi guiado
pelo dinheiro a gente trabalha porque a
gente precisa da grana e se eu perguntar
pra vocês três vezes porque você
trabalha vai tentar enganar duas e na
terceira eu vou chegar no dinheiro e
como é o dinheiro a gente se acostumou
com essa fórmula pré definida que é o
emprego onde você tenta fazer de conta
que é possível prever como será o dia de
trabalho de um ser humano e que ele vai
caber naquela descrição de cargo que é
uma grande mentira ea gente vive por
anos
nesse modelo a gente aceita que exista
hierarquia que existam cargos e que
exista rotina e aí você vai se
encaixando de uma determinada maneira e
vai perdendo sua criatividade o seu
brilho à sua paixão seu fogo e você
acaba virando o seu crachá
só que o seu crachá reflete a
expectativa que alguém tem sobre você
não é a expectativa do que você quer
colocar o mundo
então o emprego foi abafando a nossa
forma de interagir ea gente nunca
aprendeu direitinho o que a gente faz
com toda essa vontade de contribuir
fazer a diferença para o mundo
por isso o emprego vai mudar vai acabar
mas o trabalho a sua força de colocar
sua intenção no mundo impactar as
pessoas ao seu redor não vai acabar
nunca nenhum robô vai tirar de você o
brilho nos olhos de conseguir a partir
de uma interação humana e da sua força
produtiva mudar a vida de alguém
só que essa é uma responsabilidade nossa
e que a gente precisa vestir essa camisa
e a gente ainda não sabe como fazer isso
hoje a gente vive um fenômeno que eu
chamo de êxodo organizacional
as pessoas querem sair das organizações
como o grande problema do mundo do
trabalho fossem as empresas e porque
elas fazem isso
existe hoje um afastamento entre as
organizações e os indivíduos
esse afastamento acontece porque nós
estamos cada vez mais buscando autonomia
isso quer dizer que parte de nossa saída
das organizações realmente vai tentar
encontrar uma nova forma de
relacionamento produtivo mas tem gente
que fica nas organizações com mais
autonomia porque as empresas estão
mudando
existe uma máxima em rh e no mundo do
trabalho que diz que as pessoas não
pedem demissão das suas empresas
elas pedem demissão dos seus chefes e
outra máxima diz que as empresas não
demitem os seus funcionários por causa
dos seus conhecimentos
elas emitem os seus funcionários por
causa das suas atitudes
as empresas perceberam que o modelo de
trabalho pra todo lado
por isso a gente vê no futuro não vai
ter mais chefe não vai ter mais alguém
que manda em alguém o que potencialmente
pode acabar com os casamentos
o mundo do trabalho está realmente
mudando mas e as pessoas ea atitude das
pessoas diante da sua capacidade
produtiva da grande maioria de nós aqui
conhece pelo menos uma pessoa que saiu
do mundo organizacional tradicional para
começar um negócio próprio ou para se
juntar a um novo tipo de organização
para mudar este modelo do que é o
emprego tradicional possivelmente em
cada um de nós também conhece uma pessoa
que produz menos nesse modelo
ela era mais produtiva na época em que
ela trabalhava dentro da organização
talvez ela seja mais feliz mas talvez
ela não esteja entregando todo o seu
potencial
e quando você conversa com essas pessoas
e pergunta mas me conta como se deu esse
movimento por que você saiu daquele que
é o emprego que era tão bom naquela
empresa onde você era tão valorizado ea
resposta vai ser porque eu queria ter
propósito eu queria ter significado e
propósito e significado são coisas
lindas ea gente tem que ter porque por
muito tempo a gente ficou lá anestesiado
dentro do escritório fazendo alguma
coisa que alguém mandou sem entender
direito porque não ganhando também por
causa daquilo mas quando você começa a
cavar com essas pessoas que saíram do
mundo tradicional fala então tá bom me
conta um pouco sobre o propósito e
significado nem detalha um pouco que que
é isso a seguinte eu faço assim uma
coisa que eu amo eu gosto muito
eu escolho quem eu atendo e eu faço tipo
quando eu quero entende isso chama
prazer né não chama propósito porque
propósito e significado ele demanda uma
intenção e um esforço genuíno de você
costurar um raciocínio na sua cabeça
para que você enxergue um determinado
valor naquilo que você entrega ele não é
o piloto automático e o discurso batido
de eu vou atender um chamado porque
talvez o seu chamado não seja suficiente
talvez o seu chamado não seja o melhor
para o mundo
talvez o seu chamado te coloque numa
neste dia maior do que você estava nas
organizações
não use o chamado
como uma desculpa para não entregar o
seu melhor
o trabalho tem três papéis fundamentais
no relacionamento com as pessoas o
primeiro financeiro ea gente foi guiado
por muito tempo nessa roda de trabalhar
por grana ok tamo junto tô cansado não
quero mas não me diga que você está
saindo das organizações porque você quer
impacto social e psicológico se você não
faz o seu melhor
se você não se planeja se você não
entrega com qualidade
você está com preguiça você está sendo
egoísta e você está contribuindo para um
mundo menos do que aquela organização
maldita é aquele chefe desgraçado que
você falava mal você precisa vestir essa
camisa é essa responsabilidade de mudar
o seu comportamento com relação ao
trabalho agora você saiu da organização
que era cruel que está esperando para
conseguir entregar mais impacto
isso demanda muito alto conhecimento é
uma visita mais dura para sua realidade
de enxergar determinados ângulos de você
que você não gosta tanto
mas você tem que encarar porque parte do
seu discurso é mentira
você quer a paz mundial mas aquela vaca
do rh morrer melhor você olha com
compaixão para o mendigo na rua mas eu
não vou responder o e mail do financeiro
que ele é muito chato a gente não
enxerga que dentro do nosso trabalho
existe um círculo social extremamente
impactado pela gente não dá pra salvar o
mundo se você não salvar o seu grupo
social principal sua família e as
pessoas que trabalham com você então
junto com você nessa canoa furada ou não
mas a gente precisa conseguir atuar
juntos
o trabalho é a manifestação da sua
essência amorosa por meio da produção
trabalho é a manifestação da sua
que está colocando para o mundo por meio
da sua produção
seu melhor mais ou menos vamos esperar
mais um pouquinho atrasada com aquele
cliente existe uma lista de coisas que
são comuns
pra todo mundo quando a gente fala de
felicidade autonomia não pode ser a
contrapartida de perder qualidade
essa conquista que nós tivemos de ter
autonomia não pode ser uma troca por
qualidade nessa lista do que a gente
busca como realização do trabalho
a gente tem bem estar liberdade
propósito intenção e amor
mas cuidado a sua autenticidade não pode
ser tão profunda a ponto de virar
arrogância e atrapalhar o seu impacto
o seu bem estar não pode ser tão forte
exige tanto conforto a ponto de que você
fica impedido de ter crescimento a sua
liberdade não pode tolerar a sua
conquista de ter disciplina e entregar o
que você falou que ia entregar o seu
propósito não tinha isentado a
responsabilidade maior do grupo a sua
intenção não pressupõe o fim da entrega
seu amor o seu amor tem que vem com
força total na força do trabalho
mas isso é difícil a gente está
aprendendo e pra gente é complicado sair
de um histórico que a gente recebia
sempre impulsos externos para produzir
bem para ser feliz agora conversa com a
gente mesmo
eu quero saber que conversa vocês vão
ter com vocês sobre a sua capacidade de
mudar a toda não vai descer
ninguém com um manual de como a gente
resolve o mundo do trabalho
ninguém fora desse palco e nem neste
palco vai dizer pra vocês como vocês vão
construir o futuro de vocês e o futuro
do trabalho porque nós não estamos
descobrindo o futuro do trabalho
nós estamos desenhando o futuro do
trabalho e se você acha que o futuro do
trabalho vai ser um relacionamento leve
criativo colorido onde tudo se encaixa
perfeitamente compra um lego
não vai ser assim velho você vai ter que
ralar porque esforço não é sinônimo de
sofrimento você consegue fazer melhor e
que hoje o mundo precisa de verdade é do
seu melhor trabalho
faça muito obrigado
[Aplausos]